foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is
scp-3092 object class Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-3092 is to be contained in an empty
room with a single compatible power
outlet it is not to be plugged in or
stocked with toys unless actively being
tested testing with scp-3092 must be
pre-approved by at least one level three
staff member and at least one Foundation
agent armed with a mock tranquilizer
rifle previously a net launcher must be
present in order to subdue and contain
resultant
scp-3092-a instances
scp-3092-a instances are to be contained
individually in standard containment
kennels modified with two additional
locks at least one of which should be
biometrically operated in order to
prevent further containment breaches
they are to be provided amenities in
exchange for compliant Behavior but none
that could serve as tools or Aids in an
escape attempt should one or more
scp-3092-a instances successfully Escape
containment a team of Agents armed with
mock tranquilizer rifles C addendum 3092
1 and 2 should sweep the site until they
are recontained and all Personnel should
be notified of the situation be aware of
their surroundings and Report any
suspicious activity or
scp-3092-a attacks immediately
no plush toys are permitted within 200
meters of any
scp-3092-a instance outside of testing
purposes
description
scp-3092 is a black tie toys brand
arcade claw machine measuring 1.8 meters
tall 0.8 meters wide and 0.9 meters deep
and weighing approximately 144 kilograms
while on stock The Machine's body and
mechanical parts are all non-anomalous
in nature primarily composed of Steel
plastic and various Electronics all
possessing wear and tear consistent with
multiple years of regular usage
investigation has revealed that scp-3092
was in usage for seven years prior to
its anomalous property surfacing
when provided power and coins of valid
United States currency
scp-3092 may be operated as a standard
for commercially available claw machines
it's anomalous properties only activate
whenever the operator successfully picks
up one or more plush toys with the claw
and deposits them in
scp-3092's price shoot at this point the
respective plush toys will immediately
transform into instances of scp-3092-a
scp-3092-a instances are cotton stuffed
felt plush gorillas possessing no
identifying tags or logos sitting at
roughly 0.3 meters tall and weighing 0.4
kilograms they are Sapient communicative
all
scp-3092-a instances identified have
been fluent in English and capable of
sight hearing touch and ambulation of
all four limbs additionally they possess
notable manual dexterity despite seeming
to lack distinct digits and relevant
muscular structures outside of this all
instances are conventional plush toys
lacking any biological components
scp-3092-a instances are remarkably
proficient in various activities related
to guerrilla warfare such as stealth
weapon improvisation trap setting and
the maintenance and usage of a variety
of small arms they also appear to
possess ideologies crudely resembling
various real and fictitious Guerrilla
Rebel groups they are capable of
developing and staging complex plans
individually or as a group and regularly
attempt to breach containment with
limited success
however thus far all
scp-3092-a activity appears to have been
intended to annoy or inconvenience
rather than cause legitimate damage to
its targets all weapons employed by
scp-3092-a instances have been
non-lethal in nature causing only minor
injuries opportunities to cause severe
damage to Foundation assets such as
through arson or the containment breach
of other SCP objects have been ignored
in favor of more superficial attacks
attempts to question
scp-3092-a instances on the subject have
failed with all instances insisting that
their attacks are massively damaging
with many casualties implements and
tactics frequently used include
slingshots small catapults previously
trip hazards see addendum 309203
graffiti glitter bombs and buckets or
canisters of various liquids placed atop
partially opened doors
all
scp-3092-a instances created by scp-3092
have thus far possessed distinct
personalities beliefs objectives and
identities however when an instance of
scp-3092 comes into physical contact
with a non-anomalous plush toy that
plush toy will immediately be
transformed into an identical instance
of
scp-3092-a with similar Baseline
personality ideology and behavioral
patterns to the scp-3092-a instance
which created it
scp-3092-a instances appear to be aware
of this property and will attempt to
make use of it in order to bolster
numbers many instances will after being
created attempt to re-enter scp-3092 in
order to convert any applicable toys
remaining inside
scp-3092-a instances can be ripped torn
or otherwise damaged with no greater
difficulty than a conventional plush toy
reactions to damage have been
universally and melodramatically
negative with instances typically
expressing hyperbolic pain over even
superficial damage severe injuries such
as deep punctures or tears to the Torso
Detachment of limbs or decapitation will
result in death with instances falling
to the ground and ceasing to move
typically after a long period of
exaggerated expressions of pain however
in cases less severe than complete
incineration instances appear to only be
playing dead as repeated disturbance of
these corpses will result in them being
briefly returned to activity and
requesting that this disturbance stop as
they are out of the game due to this
information as well as
scp-3092-a's lack of a nervous system it
is not currently believed that they they
actually feel pain repair of damaged
scp-3092-a instances through
conventional stitching patching and
re-stuffing is typically sufficient to
alleviate instances expressed pain and
death States and is interpreted by them
as medical attention
currently 23 instances of
scp-3092-a are in containment by the
foundation
recovery
scp-3092 was retrieved on 0503-20 from
Family Restaurant and arcade in Cheyenne
Wyoming after Animal Control Officers
responding to a call there noted
anomalous activity upon Foundation
agent's arrival to The Scene It is
believed that 21
scp-3092-a instances had been created
through both scp-3092 and their own
duplication properties and restaurant
facilities were considerably defaced
after killing several aggressive
instances with small arms fire the
remaining instances surrendered to
Foundation officials and were contained
along with scp-3092 after it was
determined the source of anomalous
activity civilians present were
amnesticized and a cover story of an
escaped pet chimpanzee was distributed
addendum 309201
on 05 1820 one
scp-3092-a instance initiated a
containment bridge and fled by an
adjacent hallway agent Megan Cho
noticing this activity while standing
guard outside SCP its containment
chamber fired on the instance with a
tranquilizer rifle she was armed with
curiously the subject appeared to pass
out falling to the ground and ceasing
all activities besides occasional
twitches and mock snoring
scp-3092-a instances are not otherwise
noted to possess a regular sleep cycle
subject was recontained without incident
and awoke several hours later due to
increased Effectiveness and lowered risk
over net launchers or Firearms it is
recommended that Foundation agents use
tranquilizer weapons in the
recontainment of
scp-382-a instances in the future
addendo 3092 O2
after testing it has been determined
that any weapon firing feather-tipped
pneumatic darts is sufficient to induce
a sleep state in
scp-1392-a regardless of whether said
Dart is actually loaded with
tranquilizers like the aforementioned
death state it is believed that this
sleep state is performative on
scp-3092-ace part to minimize the
potential for collateral damage to
Foundation Personnel mock tranquilizer
rifles should be used in place of actual
tranquilizers
addendum 309203
on 0609 two scp-3092-a instances
simultaneously escaped containment and
fled through the building's ventilation
system before setting up a tripwire in
the office of Dr Martin Helmer intending
for him to trip fall and land face first
on a pillow with a crude insult written
on it however upon entering his office
Dr Helmer tripped fell hit his shoulder
against a bookshelf and suffered a
fractured collarbone an injury much more
severe than any induced by prior
scp-3092-a containment breaches upon
discovering this both instances
immediately expressed remorse informed
other Foundation officials of the
situation and were compliant in
recontainment investigation revealed
later that several amenities Within
These instances cells had been converted
into gifts and apology cards intended
for Dr Helmer further breaches by
scp-3092-a instances have not been noted
to employed trip hazards of any sort
[Music]
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening and you're all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to accept
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan James Saba
vibing Shockwave
killer Hunter Jew
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
zazapan
Lemke
signor
Olive Treon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
and oh crop guy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos found some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you